نذهب الان لهذه هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لدانييل هجار المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي المخربين في كل يوم من ايام
الحرب ونحن ناخذ
من العدو كل امكانيات امكانياته الارهابيه
التي كانت في السابع في الاكتوبر ونحن
نقدم وجبه نيران لقواتنا من الجوي
والبر كل
مكان كان فيه
حماس نصل اليه بقوه نيران من الجو والبر
وكل قوه تحتاج الى مساعده جويه تحصل عليها
القوات تواصل تعميق الحرب بمنطقه خانيونس
نحن نوسع العمليه ونكشف الانفاق ونقتل
المخربين الحرب في خانيونس مركب ونحن
وصلنا الى الكثير من المواقع تحت الارضيه
حماس وواجهنا مخربين وقتلنا مخربين
وسنواصل تعميق هذا الامر اليوم وفي الايام
القادمه اليوم نشرنا
عمليه قوات الاحتياط 5 خوا في منطقه
جباليا في عمليات القوات كشفوا عن انفاق
تخريبيه لحماس في غزه هذه السلسله من
الانفاق كانت في الشمال وفي هذه القياده
التي تبعد عشرات الامطار تحت الارض وجدنا
اسلحه وايضا وسائل وسائل قتاليه ومختبرات
لتصنيع الاسلحه وايضا غرف للبقاء في ساعات
وفيها احمد غندور قائد الذي قاد الحرب في
السابع من اكتوبر ضد دوله
اسرائيل هذه السلسله كانت مرتبطه بفتحه ال
بيت الغندور الذي قتلناه قبل عده اسابيع
هذه الانفاق كانت تحت المستشفى بالقرب من
المستشفى الاندونيسي في منطقه جباليا حماس
يعمل من خلال المناطق المدنيه ويستخدمها
لعملياته الارهابيه وايضا نحن هذا تحدي
كبير نواجهه ونقوم ونعمل به بشكل جيد
ونقدم
لقواتنا وايضا نحصل على انجازات كما حصل
في 5 خوا فخلال العمليه لاعاده المخطوفين
القوات تم التخليص داخل الفاق جثث دي بادو
والجندي شيرمن والجندي يدر وعزاريا واليا
توليدانو ليرحمهم الله نحن اخذناهم
ليدفنوا في اسرائيل الجثث تم نقلها للفحص
في المختبر الطبي وس و سنبلغ العائلات
وبعد ذلك بعد ان يؤكدوا تؤكد العائلات
سنبلغ الجمهور نحن نشارك في الام العائلات
ونحتضن نواصل السياسه التي عملناها حتى
الان وايضا نعرض الامر على العائلات وبعد
ذلك الجمهور بشكل شفاف في الشمال اليوم
اكملنا عده هجمات واسعه التي هجمنا عده
اهداف عسكريه لحزب الله وبينها بنا
ارهابيه ومناطق لاطلاق السق ايضا بالامس
قتلنا عدد من مخربي حزب الله ايضا كان هنا
ع اق من جانب لبنان وقوتنا ردت باطلاق
النار حالا
اسئله القنا 14 لقواتنا الكثير من
الاصابات في شمالي قطاع غزه وكيف
هذا يتسق مع الامور في جباليه وال
الشجاعيه نحن في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي كان
الكثير من الاصابات وايضا عن ع
من قوات جيش الدفاع من نتيجه هذا هذه
الحوادث كل حادث من هذه الحوادث هو مختلف
وهذا جزء من الحرب وعلى الجمهور ان يعرف
ذلك لا يمكن تفكيك حماس بدون العمليه
البريه الطريق التي نعمل ضد الانفاق التي
بطريقه حماس قاد الحرب في سابع من اكتوبر
هناك اسلحه الذي قام شغلها ض ضدنا
وايضا نخرج المخربين الى الخارج العمليه
البريه ايضا تحسن وتمكننا من ان ناخذ
الاستخبارات لاعاده المخطوفين كل هذه
الامور معا تعطي ضغطا على حماس ونحن نعمل
في منطقه خانيونس تحت الارض ل نقتل مخربين
وايضا نصل لتحت الارض وهذا ما يضغط على
حماس كما قمنا بذلك في الماضي وحتى وقف
اطلاق النار نحن زدنا القوه وسنعمل وسنعمل
كذلك حتى الان
وايضا في اللغه العسكريه ما تعني السيطره
العسكريه في السيطره العسكريه يمكن ان
نقوم بعمليات وايضا في المنطقه وه
هو السيطره العسكريه في في غزه عندما
قسمناها من منطقه البحر حتى الشيخ عجلين
وحتى منطقه بيري كل ما يمكن في الشمال نحن
نحارب الليله في درجه التفاح وهذه المنطقه
الاخيره التي فيها قوات لحماس كل المنطقه
نحن منتشرون نسيطر على المنطقه ولكن هذه
المنطقه التي طهرنا وسيطرنا على معظم
البنى التحت ارضيه لحماس وايضا كشفناه
للجمهور وكشفنا اليوم للجمهور واحد اخرى
وهذا الانجاز الكبير في الشمال ولدينا
الكثير من العمل والانجازات في الجنوب في
خان يونس وهو نسيطر نركز عليه
الان القناه
12 الوزير بنفير يقول بانه بسبب التوقف
الحرب لاعاده المخطوفين هذا مكن من اصابات
اكثر وهل هذا الامر واقعي كما ترون انتم
نحن نقوم بحرب مركبه ومعقده ضد عدو وحشي
وللحرب هدف واحد هو تفكيك حماس وايضا هناك
هدف اخر وهو اعاده المخطوفين
الجهود لاعاده المخطوفين جيش الدفاع يعرف
كيف يتعامل مع هذه التركيبات وايضا مع هذه
الاهداف وايضا وصلنا الى توقف لاطلاق
النار من اجل اعاده مخطوفين وهذا احد
اهداف الحرب وجيش الدفاع يمكن من الوضع
العملياتي للقيام بذلك السبب الوحيد ان
الصفقه هذه خرجت الى النور الضغط العسكري
ضد حماس وط من ذلك طلب حماس ان
اطلاق النار نحن مكنا الشروط من اجل اعاده
المخطوفين
وايضا في خلال توقف قتلنا مخربين ايضا
وهذه ضمن العمليات
ونحن لم نقلل من استعدادنا وايضا عملياتنا
وانا علي ان اقول اننا ركزنا في الشمال
اليوم
الشمال مره اخرى اعيد على السؤال الاول
الشمال تحت السيطره العسكريه
نحن نكمل ما عندنا في درجه التفاح ونركز
على الجنوب ولذلك ل انا لا انظر
الى ما قاله وزير
اخر ان حماس ان توقف اطلاق النار مكن حماس
من السيط من الاستعداد بحماس في نهايه
الامر يجب عليه ان يعيد وسائل
قتاليه الجهود لمواجهه حماس لا طريق اخرى
يجب قتل القاده ون على تحت الارض وايضا ان
ناخذ الاسلحه ونقتل المخربين هذا ما يعني
تفكيك حماس وفي في نهايه الامر سيكون بعض
الارهاب مناطق الارهاب وايضا يجب ان لا
نوهم الجمهور سيكون هناك بعض مناطق
الارهاب وايضا ان يقوم بذلك كما حدث في
السابع في اكتوبر لا يمكن هذا هد هدفنا
وايضا لم نوقف ذلك في توقف اطلاق النار
وحتى اذا توقف و مره اخرى وعندما يبلغون
بذلك ونحن نتقدم نحو الهدف ان نواصل تفكيك
حماس 11 هل يمكن ان تكون المخاوف من انفاق
الشمال وكما قال رؤساء السلطات المحليه لم
اكن في هذا الحديث
مع قائد المنطقه نحن نعمل في الدفاع ونحن
نفحص معلومات لدي بهذا الامر ويجب ان اقول
الجمهور لا معلومات لدينا كما اظهر ذلك
رئيس قائد الجبهه في الشمال نحن نهاجم
بشكل واسع ونحن نفحص وايضا ان لا لا نبقي
شيء عندما يكون لدينا معلومات استخباريه
سنبلغ الجمهور لا يوجد شيء كهذا لا توجد
معلومات استخباريه حول
ذلك
قال قائد كبير ان الامر يحتاج الى عده
اشهر حتى جيش الدفاع يسيطر على خان يونس
وهل يمكن ان يتوقف الامر بدون السيطره على
خان يونس هناك الكثير من اطلاق النار على
قواتنا اطلاق النار الداخلي هل جيش الدفاع
يقوم بالتحقيق من اجل التخفيف من هذه
الحواد كل عمليه نقوم بالتحقيق فيها وايضا
اليوم كنت مع رئيس الاركان في القياده
الجنوبيه رئيس الاركان كان في الميدان
وعرضوا عليه الخطط كل يوم نحن نوائب الخطط
وايضا نظر الى هذه الخطط وايضا كانت هناك
واعطانا توجيهات مما قام به العدو ونقوم
بعمليات من اجل ان نقلل الاصابات في
قواتنا كل يوم نقوم به وايضا نعمل من اجل
تامين امن قواتنا وفيما يتعلق ب
لم لم استمع الى هذا التقرير ايضا فيما
يتعلق بخان يونس هذا ياخذ وقتا نحن مصممون
على القيام بذلك ونحن مستعدون لذلك وهناك
خطه على مراحل للقيام بذلك من اجل تفكيك
حماس يجب ان نفكك مواقع
حماسي ناخذ القدرات العسكريه لكي يكون مره
اخرى السابع من اكتوبر لا في الجنوب ولا
في الحدود الاخرى كما نشر في القناه 11
حول قائد في جولاني الذين منعوا على
المحاربين في وقت الراحه ان يزوروا
العائلات التي قتل افرادها كيف يمكن ان
تعالجوا هذا الموضوع قبل كل شيء اريد ان
يقول لا لا حظر على ذلك المحاربون ياخذون
ياخذون ل يخرجون للانتعاش
وايضا فيما يتعلق بال الجنازات اصدقائهم
يصلون اليها وايضا يصلون الى هذه الجنازات
ونحن نمكن المحاربين من ان يواجهوا او
يلتقوا هذه العائلات اذا كان سوء فهم نحن
سنصلح الامر لا يوجد شيء كهذا وايضا
العائلات العائلات الكله هذا امر مقدس من
ان اجل ان يكون اصدقائهم في السلاح ان
يزورهم ونحن نمكن من ذلك من اجل ان نح
العائلات شكرا لكم ومساء الخير